he's uh phillip rivers he's now with the
colts which
sounds strange to say it how did it feel
when you put on that colts uniform for
the first time
um it felt good you know it's certainly
uh
uh different uh when you put on the same
uniform for 16 years but
uh it felt it felt good it's not it's
nice there's some blue in it so kind of
in a lot of ways
uh a lot of ways felt right at home
didn't feel like you were cheating on
somebody no no it's uh
maybe had been you know early march and
i felt
but shoot it's we kicked this thing off
here in two and a half weeks so
uh feels good what about all your
chargers gear where's that
uh i have it all i kept it all you know
that was that was an interesting part of
the whole move
um i said i don't think there's any
reason to bring it to indiana but we'll
certainly
certainly save it and bring it back out
one day how about a garage sale
i think we'll hang out hang on to it it
drives my wife crazy that i'll keep
every sweatshirt and a pair of
sweatpants that i've gotten over the
years but uh
yeah we got them all all saved up you're
a hoarder
i mean i i don't know i just have a
heart yeah not not too bad
not too bad but there'll be an old you
know
chargers 17 shirt from 2008
and she'll go why are you keeping that
but you can't help it do you have nc
state gear at home
i do have some nc state yeah bring that
out you know
during the season i'm sure it's the same
everywhere it gets to friday saturday
and you start to
represent your your school around the
locker room so nc state stuff usually
comes out in the fall
it's tough enough to play the position
at a high level now you're
changing you know going from the west
coast to the midwest a new team here
late in your career how difficult is
this now
trying to get everybody together on the
same page as the team leader
well you know it's definitely a
challenge but i do think uh
being in a similar scheme and and system
has been helpful
and also being with uh frank and nick
again uh
so we we communicate we know we're on
the same page from that standpoint and
what we're trying to get done so that
has been very helpful
you know people are asking me how is it
going to take with getting go getting
used to receivers and all that that's
been really good you know that's another
thing with nick being the receiver coach
in san diego
for all those years um the the things
have been taught here the little nuances
of the routes
and the uh conversions and all those
things are exactly the same so it's what
i'm used to
so that certainly has helped um and it
we got a good group we got a good group
so it's a challenge every day because
you
there's little things that come up that
you think gosh
uh you know you're used to things
happening in a certain way it's like
well yeah we haven't had that come up in
a practice with this particular player
or this
adjustment and so they're good every day
we learn something
and and get better and it's just got to
happen at an accelerated
uh curve because of uh how close we are
now to kickoff
what do you miss about california
well i i think i guess the weather uh
the weather's the only thing that's uh
that's different here so far i mean from
a standpoint of
uh when you get in training camp mode uh
you certainly you miss some of your your
buddies and people you've been around
that you're used to seeing around the
facility uh but um other than that when
you get in training camp mode you you're
all about you're all about the team
you're on and
and getting better every day so i've
really been uh
thankful and uh enjoyed getting to know
this locker room this group of guys this
support staff this coaching staff it's
really been a lot of fun to come into
work every day
how much thought did you give to not
playing this year
opting out uh none
uh none really i mean i never even got
got even
to where i was a real uh discussion with
your wife
yeah it was we were shoot uh
unless there have been some cra i can't
even think of the uh you know
kind of the um what could have happened
what i don't even know what the
parameters could have been to make it
become a discussion but
as everything kind of got situated um
felt good about it
you look at you and you look at brady
and ben
and you look at drew brees and
what is it about that position that you
can be in your late 30s
early 40s and still play at a high level
well i think we've obviously seen uh the
quarterback position is evolving a
little bit in a sense of knowledge
you're better off if you can throw it
and run it
yeah could you ever run it yeah i don't
i don't
that's last option that's the last
option for me
and if i'm out there and it looks like i
may run i always tell
could you outrun brady right now uh it'd
be a heck of a race
but i like my chances
you could get roethlisberger couldn't
you i don't know now ben
i don't know ben ben's definitely uh
got a little more uh agile on this
agileness is that a word a little more
agility to him
than i do when it comes to moving around
um but you know i think really with our
position
and i think that's why you can still uh
do it at this level
ultimately if there's gonna be a third
and seven you gotta make play from the
pocket and
and and at the end at the end of the day
i think that's what carries it you
certainly
you can get out of things when you can
run it and do all those things but i
think that's what has a have allowed
you know us traditional pastors to to
play uh
you know at the age we are um and i
think too it's it's about how quickly
you can
process and see it and get the ball out
of your hand and get the ball to the
playmaker so
um you know every every system and every
every team has a little different
philosophy
uh but i think with what we do
system-wise and and the skilled players
we have
that uh at 38 or in brady's case at
42-43 you can still
still get it done these phillip rivers
the colts quarterback it still sounds
strange to say that are your kids all in
on you
you know the colts and nobody is uh sort
of
still uh a charger fan no it's amazing
what that uh
that family loyalty runs deep it's it's
i mean it's like snap your fingers and
it's
it's all colts all of a sudden ty's a
receiver and this and then they're going
you know the whole deal
um i think they they still will because
of how long i was there and really some
of them had
as they've gotten older you know um you
know the keenan
allen's and the hunter henry's and those
guys they'll still they'll still pull
for those guys as will i
uh but i think yeah they quickly adjust
they had more colts gear than i had
right off the bat i mean dad can i can i
click this can i order this can i order
this so
there was a colts gear early early in
the spring
once the thing got ironed out we talked
to bose a couple of weeks ago he
still can't name all your kids yeah
that's that
i i i can uh i can understand that
i can understand that you know joey
being a younger player when he got there
and in the last three years in la we
were
a little bit removed from the whole uh
scene
family-wise because we were still down
in san diego so
joey didn't quite get as much
interaction with the family as
as some of the older veterans so every
all the kids are there with you in
indy we're all here yeah we're all here
did you drive or did they fly to get out
there
no you know we flew so we were down in
florida for uh you know about
six months before we came we came up
here first of june to try to get settled
in before training camp and we did so
it's good you know i think being from
north alabama i know there's like all
this competition
you know demographic-wise like
location-wise where you are you know
the south the midwest everybody's a
little biased and territorial but
it does feel a little like the south to
us it feels a lot like north alabama
from a standpoint of
you know both the weather the
neighborhoods the people that everything
so
it's been a uh it's been a good
transition uh we've
we've uh we've enjoyed it did alabama
recruit you
no not really i can't say they did um
auburn did we know that story but
alabama alabama had tyler watts you'll
remember these guys and andrew zao
you remember those two names they were
both red shirts sophomores when i was
coming out and then brody crowell was
kind of already in the
in the works that was a year or two
behind me so uh they didn't take a
quarterback that year at least that's
what i told everybody they weren't
they weren't recruiting a quarterback
that's why i wasn't on their radar is it
because you couldn't grow those bama
bangs remember
remember there was a run there where
john parker wilson didn't he have the
bama bangs there
oh yeah yeah you had to be able to do
the swoop you know you had to
you had to be able to flip it over yeah
so i i already didn't qualify
uh the expectations if you're going to a
team that is a playoff team how
important was
that that you if you were going to play
you were going to a team that had a
chance to
win a super bowl yeah it was definitely
important i mean i
i still uh you always believe wherever
you are you can win uh but it was
definitely important
uh and this this franchise this
organization
uh the head coach the whole whole deal
you just know it's it's
it's moving in the right direction uh
played them last year
and then just seeing what they've done
over the last couple years you knew it
was a
it was a franchise of the team that was
hungry and ready to
to uh to make a run so um you know we're
we're one day at a time i know it's the
i know it's the boring old answer but
one day at a time just keep getting
better and
keep your head down and work but our
guys have really
shown that and we do that so uh but it's
a heck of a group
it's one that's you know i i just feel
like top to bottom we got
there's a lot of a lot of good players
in there uh and
um a good a good team uh led by a great
head coach and
and we're excited to see what see what
we can do i've never had this
conversation with you but i put your
name up for
the next tv job i think you'd be great
in tv i don't know if you've discussed
that with your wife was there a
possibility that maybe
you would have done or will do tv
instead of
playing football yeah you know i don't i
don't know that instead of playing
football but i i don't that's something
i definitely don't want to say
rule out for sure uh certainly um
you know humbling to even be in being a
conversation
with those possibilities but i you know
i i do want to coach football
uh and you know that's been it's been
public that i'm
going to coach high school football and
south alabama when uh
when the dust settles i want to coach my
boys and do that so
i don't want to rule out the the tv side
of it but i just
i feel like uh i belong on the sideline
in a locker room with those 15 to 18
year old boys i just
i feel like that's uh kind of going to
be my second stop
uh when the dust settles here with my
plane career do you have
a a child who's similar in age to
somebody who's a teammate
like what's what's the uh how old's your
oldest yeah oldest is 18 so
i'm sure there's some 21 i'd sure
there's probably 21 year olds in there
but i know there's 22.
oh my god i want to say jonathan taylor
was born in 98 and 99
and i was a senior playing my fall
season senior year in high school
so now now i'm handing it off to it you
know michael pittman jr i played with
his dad
i played against his dad played against
his dad in denver in 2008 i think
i was going to pass himself and i guess
at that time
i heard some stories with brady too as
well with playing with a played with
played with anyway so yeah it's uh it's
it's gotten to that point good to catch
up with you and uh have fun this year
thanks enjoy